what's going on everybody Welcome to BR
fantasy I'm your host Ian Hardis on
behalf of PFF happy week 11 hope you're
having a wonderful Thursday got a great
show planned for you guys in a minute
but want to go through some of the big
news from this afternoon first first of
all we are not getting the six feet of
snow in Buffalo maybe they're still
getting it I don't know but the game's
now going to be played from the friendly
confines of Ford Field over in Detroit
so gonna be five games in Detroit in a
matter I'm sorry two games for the bills
in Detroit in a matter of five days with
them also playing Thanksgiving against
the Lions but yes Josh Allen and the
Cleveland Browns they will be indoors
this week so don't have to worry so much
about all that snowfall impacting your
fantasy squads also me Cole Hardman
placed on injured reserve with that
abdomen injury and JuJu Smith Schuster
is still not practicing with that
concussion yes that is Kadarius Tony's
music assuming Juju is not going to be
playing this week I will have Tony as a
top 20 wide receiver just gonna have too
much volume from Patrick freaking my
home so have him anywhere near that
fantasy bench also might be getting
Keenan Allen and Mike Williams back
potentially that's right could be
Keenan's First full game potentially
since week one tried to come back a
little bit too early with that hamstring
but back-to-back practices start the
week and Mike Williams as well dealing
with that knee issue we have Gus Edwards
and Mark Andrews both on track to suit
up on Sunday they have been banged up
and missing some time but over the buy
able to get healthy and John Harbaugh
has already said he does expect them to
be able to go out there also David
Montgomery looking like he's going to do
what Dave Montgomery does and that is
put up unexpected fantasy points
throughout the second half of every
single season that said with Khalil
Herbert on IR with the hip Montgomery
did not practice on Wednesday their
personal reasons he came back and did
get a full practice in on Thursday so
Dave Montgomery top 15 running back the
rest of the way because that sweet sweet
volume and it Bears offense thanks
thanks to Justin fields that is finally
starting to score a good amount of
points weekend and week out Ezekiel
Elliott is practicing and expects to
play it through that knee injury the
reason I'm grimacing is because I
probably have way too much Tony Pollard
exposure for a rational fantasy manager
out here but yes is looking like with
Zeke back him and Paul are going to
continue to be splitting things as much
as Twitter would prefer they don't final
notes jury duty not practicing with an
ankle with Dave and the joku is
practicing with an ankle Matthew
Stafford fully practicing on Wednesday
clearing the concussion protocol
expected to start on Sunday too bad his
BFF Cooper cup will not be there
alongside him so with that everyone
welcome to be our Fantasy Live presented
by State Farm fantastic show lined up
for you all today I want to go through
some of the Fantasy X factors we have
for the fantasy football playoffs
traditionally week 15 through week 17.
so a couple weeks ago we actually went
ahead and looked at the strength of
schedules by position over the course of
I think it was week 10 to week 14.
wanted to get you guys a head start on
finding those best players to help get
you into the playoff hunt and now we're
back to help show you the players that
you'll need to actually take advantage
of being in the playoff hunt in the
first place so going through
quarterbacks running backs wide
receivers tight ends and even some
defenses that have the best schedules in
weeks 15-17 so I do have some handy
dandy charts that we will be showing
throughout this show and the easiest way
to know what's going on here blue is
good and red is bad I understand that
green is good sometimes but when you do
green and red our lovely colorblind
folks out there are not able to Cipher
that quite as easily so blue good red
bad and I got it sorted so all the good
teams are going to be at the top so
we're gonna get things started with the
quarterback position and work our way
down and guys once you start looking at
the big five here we have the Texans the
Jets the 49ers the Panthers and the
Steelers kind of a shame to see three of
the top five quarterbacks you know
moving forward on offenses that we want
nothing to do with but that's the way
the cookie crumbles sometimes so again
the way I did get these schedules to
show how good and bad they are you can
actually take the fantasy points allowed
to each position from these defenses put
them into a grid average it out and you
got this ranking so again Houston Jets
49ers Panthers and the Steelers popping
us having the best playoff matchups here
for weeks fifth 18-17 quarterback I want
to focus on the two quarterbacks that
maybe we could actually wrap our minds
around suiting up during these weeks and
being a relevant fantasy starter first
up is gonna be Steelers quarterback
Kenny Pickett so guys
not been a great start for Kenny Pickett
in fact I went ahead and I looked at who
was averaging the most yards per
drawback in terms of passing yards
scramble yards and even sack yards total
yards per drop back and Kenny Pickett
was unfortunately dead last that said
we've talked about it on this stream
every single Thursday about just how
tough of a start it was for this guy I
mean think about this he comes out at
halftime he relieves Miss trubisky
against sauce Gardner in the New York
Jets that we found out they're quite
quite the defense to be dealing with
then they go into Buffalo then he plays
the Buccaneers and gets concussed his
reward coming back back-to-back road
trips to against the Dolphins and then
the Eagles before the buy so no last
week it didn't look incredible out there
but he did continue to show some low-key
rushing upside and he turned in his
first top 12 fantasy finish of the
season so Kenny Pickett looking ahead to
weeks 15 to 17 he gets the Panthers the
Raiders and the Ravens so we've seen him
have at least 20 rushing yards in three
straight games he already has three
rushing touchdowns this season I do
believe that Kenny Pickett and the 12th
most past happy off offense in the
league excluding garbage time situations
could be a quarterback down the stretch
where we look up and we're surprised to
see the back to back to back potentially
qb1 finishes so no I'm not planning on
ranking picker as the top five or top
six quarterback during that stretch but
again compared to some of these other
streamer types the Goths the heinekes of
the world I do think Kenny Pickett could
have a pretty nice end of the season to
build on a lot of weapons in that
Steelers offense more on them in just a
bit the other quarterback that is being
set up awfully well in weeks 15 through
17 49ers signal caller Jimmy Garoppolo
so unlike Pickett and some of these
other guys if you've ever watched Jimmy
Garoppolo play football you know that
we're not going to be getting that
rushing upside except on Sunday night
apparently when he had the vulture our
guy CMC at the one yard line but the
occasional goal line QB sneak uh aside
we've seen Jimmy G actually put up some
decent fantasy numbers this year because
that can be life in an offense when you
get to throw the ball to Debo Samuel
Brandon I of George Kittle and now
Christian McCaffrey out there so if you
actually look at Jimmy G's last five
games he's turned in finishes as the qb8
11 7 14 and most recently in 19 so again
similar to pick it I'm not expecting
either of these guys to be up there in
the conversation with Patrick Mahomes
and Josh Allen and Jalen hurts but again
that's why we're trying to give you guys
that are probably on your waiver wire
and you can take advantage of moving
forward so Jimmy G he's in the sort of
offense where we don't necessarily need
40 pass attempts or a bunch of Rush
attempts to make the most out of it
because he just needs to exist in that
brief time between getting the snap and
getting the ball into the hands of some
of his Playmakers no quarterback is
averaging more yards per attempt on
passes behind the line of scrimmage than
Jimmy Garoppolo if you actually look
back over the past five years Sean McVay
and Kyle Shanahan have been by far the
best coaches at getting the most out of
these again quote unquote passes behind
a line of scrimmage but hey guess what
passing yards getting on the screens
those pop passes all count the same in
Fantasyland so Jimmy G and the 49ers
they get the Seahawks the commanders and
the Raiders in weeks 15 217 don't be
afraid to expect some Boom games there
potentially from Jimmy G
I want to get to the chat real quick
before we move on to running backs
appreciate you guys always tuning in
live with us every single Thursday at 5
PM Eastern so from at rpr start
Christian Watson or Nico Collins we're
going to Christian Watson route guys and
it's honestly a similar reasoning as
when we were getting behind Romeo Dobbs
and I understand it wasn't the most
consistent performances out there but at
the end of the day this still is the
two-time reigning League MVP Aaron
Rodgers that if you saw that Cowboys
game last week I mean Watson could have
had four touchdowns if he didn't lose
that one down the sideline in the light
so really nothing wrong with Aaron
Rodgers's arm we're not looking at this
2015 Payton or 2020 Drew Brees type of
situation here so he just needed these
guys to get healthy I mean no one even
looked at the package before the season
started as having a good group of pass
catchers I think they were pretty
consensuously a bottom five unit and
lizards had shoulder injuries Watson's
been the concussion protocol on
hamstring issues Cobb is just now coming
back from IR Romeo Dobbs is on IR I
believe if not he is awfully banged up
so you already took a bad receiving room
and then you took away the starters and
had to rely on the backups no wonder
things were so tough for them now
they're getting healthy I do expect
consistency down the road from Watson as
an upside wide receiver three from at JC
Lebanon McLaren Rondell Moore a Kadarius
Tony at Flex good problem to have my
friend I am going to go with scary Terry
here eighth in the NFL in receiving
yards Terry McLaren and he is I believe
going to have a shadow match up in
Houston against rookie Texans cornerback
Derek Stingley Jr so third overall pick
he has flashed at different points this
year but he's just been a little bit in
over his head they are using him to
Shadow the opposition's number one wide
receiver game after game and we've seen
guys like Cortland Sutton like Devonte
Adams amongst others go for over 100
yards without all that much of an issue
so Terry McLaren I mean come on have you
guys seen this dude over the last three
four weeks or heinecke under Center he
has beaten jair Alexander Stefan Gilmore
and Darius Slay like drums over the past
month of action continuing to be one of
the most underrated wide receivers in
football you know I think he deserves to
now be crowned Our Generations version
of Alan Robinson and Andre Johnson where
just Time After Time doesn't matter who
the quarterback is the guy is putting up
big time numbers love watching Terry
play
and with that guys let's get back to
some more X factors here for the
playoffs looking at specifically
specifically now running backs again
with these charts blue good red is bad
and we got it sorted so all the good
schedules for weeks 15 to 17 in terms of
their opponents fantasy points allowed
to the position are going to be at the
top of the list so the top five Fantasy
Playoff schedules at running back the
Chiefs the Jets the Saints the Steelers
and the Titans so a little bit better
than uh you know the quarterback
situations where we don't have to worry
about guys like Zach Wilson and all that
we actually have a chance to take
advantage of the other guys so with the
Jets actually Michael Carter and even
James Robinson I'm not sure if this
could be clearing up by then but God
forbid one of them gets injured or
something could be a nice little stretch
there obviously Derrick Henry and one of
the cool things with Derrick Henry guys
I have found though if you look at his
yards per carry by month he only gets
better as it goes I mean in September I
believe he's actually under four yards
for Kerry during his career it goes up a
little bit in uh October but November
December and January 5.5 5.5 5.1 yards
for carry though you love one like the
stats actually add up with what should
be happening and what is happening is
that that 260 pound Beast gets harder
and harder to tackle as the weather gets
colder we have seen that come to
fruition and then obviously with the
Saints Alvin Kamar you're feeling good
about that too but I want to focus in
the two situations where again I think
there could be some actionable moves for
you guys to make on the wafer wire
potentially and that starts off with the
best schedule in weeks 15 to 17. Isaiah
Pacheco and the Kansas City Chiefs
coming off the first game of the season
where Claude Edwards Solaire completely
out of the committee didn't even have a
carry just six percent of the snaps out
there so no Pacheco didn't turn forward
the biggest game himself but guys he is
looking at potentially 15 plus touches
on a near weekly basis moving forward in
the top ranked scoring offense in the
league so you're telling me when we look
at the schedule Houston Seattle and
Denver in those three games if that's
not something Pacheco can smash come on
man so I would also note that you know
in week 17 this Broncos defense is legit
I am not trying to you know put them
down anything like the reason why the
Chiefs are popping so much in this
metric is more so because of the Houston
Seattle metrics but we've also seen this
Broncos team this year going downhill I
would not be surprised if by week 17
they don't have too much to play for and
to be fair that game is also an
arrowhead where it's kind of like okay
who really can't stop Patrick Mahomes at
home in that sort of environment so
again it's a two-man backfield in Kansas
City Isaiah Pacheco maybe even Jared
McKinnon could be supplying more fancy
goodness than not when it matters most
another combo with some pretty good
schedules here looking ahead to the
fantasy playoffs Naji Harris and Jalen
Warren in Pittsburgh so look I don't
think anyone has probably been rage
dropping Naji Harris out there I
wouldn't necessarily blame you if you
have but Jalen Warren is a guy that you
should be trying to get on your rosters
if at all possible and I think the ESPN
ownership guys is still under that 10
Mark so Jalen Warren continues to be a
player that honestly I think is in that
Tony Pollard Alexander Madison tier of
handcuffs because we've seen over the
years Le'Veon Bell DeAngelo Williams
James Connor even Naji Harris last year
doesn't matter who the running back has
been in Pittsburgh they've been willing
to give them a true every down role and
with Naji Harris this year he really
hasn't quite been getting fed as much as
he has last year because of the presence
of Jalen Warren and this undrafted
rookie guys been fantastic to start the
year I mean if you just look at his
Advanced metrics here normal yards per
carry 6 16th among 66 qualify backs but
goes up to 15th and yards after contact
and sixth and Miss talk was forced had
this awesome hurdle last week on the
reception where he was accelerating
through it matches the eye test and
again we have a good running back and an
offense with a great schedule Panthers
Raiders and Ravens down the stretch and
similar to what I was talking about with
Denver kind of a bad team where with
Naji Harris already dealing with that
knee injury where Mike Tomlin said he's
going to play but it couldn't lead to
him being limited I don't know
Pittsburgh you know loses another three
or four games over the next few weeks
are they going to continue to try out
Naji out there when they have zero
percent chance of making the playoffs
wouldn't be the most surprising thing to
see Jalen Warren potentially emerged as
this year's version of Rashad Penny down
the stretch hopefully leading you to
those fantasy championships
back to the chat guys at Jesse Stewart
Patterson or Foreman standard League
I've tried to be really fair to Arthur
Smith throughout this year as much as
it's been easy to be like I'll throw the
ball more to Kyle Pitts and Drake London
at the end of the day this was a top 10
offense for the first eight nine weeks
of the season and like Arthur Smith said
himself you know he was winning games
he's not concerned about fantasy well
now he's stopped winning games and it's
a little bit messed up guys I proudly am
the President of the Cordero Patterson
fan club been in my Twitter bio for five
plus years unfortunately I gotta go with
Deontay Foreman because my man C Pat got
six touches in a rainy Thursday night
game unforgivable move from Arthur Smith
if he had someone else great going fine
go ahead don't give me Tyler Alger
turning 11 touches into three yards be
better Arthur Smith and from Michael l b
Sutton Watson or van Jefferson so I
would say Watson over sudden if everyone
was healthy in Denver but at this point
guys I mean Jerry Judy still hasn't been
practicing this week with the ankle
injury KJ Handler is going to miss
several weeks with the hamstring injury
obviously Tim Patrick completely out of
the picture since the summer so it's
just sad to me like I was doing my
rankings this week and I expecting those
guys to be out you know I put coral and
Sutton like wide receiver 18 wide
receiver 19 and like could you imagine
going back into August and telling
someone like hey Judy's going to be out
handlers out Patrick's already out
Sutton would have been a top 10 guy
probably at that point unfortunately
that's life in this sad sad Denver
Broncos offense but speaking of wide
receivers let's go go ahead and move on
to the top schedules weeks 15 to 17 for
the wide receiver position at the top of
our handy dandy charts we have all the
good squads in blue specifically looking
at the Ravens Texans Packers Browns and
the Panthers so gonna focus in on
Cleveland and Green Bay in a second but
I would say with Baltimore popping there
uh before the show started we were going
over some of the IR guys that you want
or don't want and unfortunately guys
Rashad Bateman isn't coming back anytime
soon so Devin someone that has been you
know finding the end zone an awful lot
this year wouldn't be surprised if he
does you know flirt with some higher end
outcomes right when it matters most in
fantasy
also keep an eye on the Texans someone
had a start sick question about Nico
Collins earlier and even though I
wouldn't have taken them in that
specific question could have some nice
games here down the stretch and finally
looking at that Carolina offense with TJ
Moore I know it's been tough guys but
maybe PJ Walker is recovered by then or
Sam darnold gives them a spark man
listen to myself we're hoping like Sam
dardo could potentially Elevate this
passing game you could imagine if the
schedule persists but let's go ahead and
talk about again some of these guys I
think we could go out there and get on
the waiver wire starting with the Browns
and look I get it Amari Cooper certainly
someone that's been on your teams all
year and giving you far more good than
bad but Donovan people's Jones is
someone that just keeps on keeping on
even with the radic Jacoby Brissette
under center dpj now six straight games
with at least 50 receiving yards and
five of those six games over 70
receiving yards so no hasn't scored a
touchdown this year that can be life in
a Jacoby Brissette LED offense but guess
what guys only a few more weeks of that
percent LED offense before we get the
Sean Watson back in Action so whatever
your thoughts are on Watson he has been
a quarterback historically that has been
able to lead top five passing games put
up all sorts of points so remember when
will Fuller was able to be his you know
full-time field stretcher and had a lot
of big booms over the years when he was
able to be healthy enough to be out
there on the field Donovan people's
Jones does profile as his offenses feel
stressed you're with Amari Cooper you
know being in more of that DeAndre
Hopkins mode if we want to go ahead and
look at that 2019-2020 Texan Squad as a
comparison I know he left in 2020. you
guys could imagine but look weeks 15
through 17 the Ravens the Saints and the
commanders I mean these are even games
too considering how bad the Browns
defense is 31st and scoring 31st in the
EPA allowed per play I wouldn't be all
that shocked if we see the Browns
getting some of these fantasy friendly
shootouts that guys like the Bears and
the Lions have been having this year
because
once you have Watson back we're
generally looking at an offense that
could be flirting with top five status
themselves and the defense is that bad
so that's the ideal combo in fantasy
football we want all the guys getting
good fantasy friendly volume on offense
and we want their defense to suck so
they have to keep that pedal to the
metal all game long
love to chat at IAD Pollard McLaren or
Christian Watson at Flex if Zeke stays
out which he said today he's planning on
playing this week I would go with
Pollard otherwise though I'm gonna take
Terry McLaren here again great matchup
this week against a rookie cornerback
and Derek Stingley Jr who has a bright
future ahead of him but he has been a
bit in over his head in one-on-one
matchups like this and Terry hard to
find a better player this year at the
feeding Shadow coverage from at a tone
Pacheco or Jamal Williams I'm gonna lean
barely towards Pacheco in this one it's
actually very close I think they're both
in that same kind of rb2 range because
we know there's going to be another
running back taking the pass down work
for Jamal it's either Swift or Justin
Jackson oddly enough sadly enough for
DeAndre Swift fantasy managers and with
Pacheco as great as you know this new
early down role is Jared McKinnon
outscored him last week because Jared
McKinnon is going to get more of the
fantasy friendly pass down uh stuff so I
do think their probable touch count is
pretty similar both Skies getting
between 15 and 20 touches and at that
point give me the guy playing for the
Chiefs not the guy playing for the Lions
one other wide receiver combo I want to
talk about having a real nice you know
Fantasy Playoff stretch here coming up
is the Green Bay Packers we got a lot of
questions on Christian Watson and look
guys I'm not expecting him to score you
know three touchdowns in another game
the rest of the season or anything but
again the role here matters we now have
a full-time wide receiver with day two
draft capital and an offense led by the
two-time reigning MVP so Christian
Watson in weeks 15-17
we'll get a chance to Feast on the Rams
the Dolphins and the Vikings so Rams not
the easiest but Jalen Ramsey not
expected to be shattering him in that
matchup and it's one of those situations
where are the Rams really going to be
playing for that much more in week 15
and I mean if cups still out of the
picture their playoff chances are done
are we still going to see Donald and
Ramsey being asked to go out there and
be playing at a full-time level so we'll
see with that but the Dolphins and the
Vikings I mean these are quarterback
rooms that have been a mix of injured
and bad throughout this season could be
some great spots there Fort Watson and
Lazard and I would say you know just
looking at these games specifically I do
think that we get the Dolphins game in
Miami not Green Bay so could be a
situation where we avoid some of that
Lambo snow don't have to worry too much
about that and with that guys let's move
on and talk about some tight ends here
as always blue good red bad I've taken
all the average fantasy points per game
Allowed by these defenses looked at the
schedule calculated it up and with that
we have our top five fantasy football
schedules for the the playoffs with
tight ends number one is going to be the
New York Jets number two the New England
Patriots that said as we know Hunter
Henry and John new Smith tend to cancel
each other out number three the Arizona
Cardinals Trey McBride more on him in
just a minute the Carolina Panthers are
number four again when you have two or
three real-life tight ends you usually
have none in fantasy so Tommy tremble
and even my namesake Ian Thomas is tough
to get behind them with the lack of
volume at hand and finally the Kansas
City Chiefs so if you drafted Travis
Kelsey in round one back in August
there's a good chance you'll be feeling
awesome about the numbers he's putting
up when it matters most but focusing on
the two situations of guys that we could
actually go out there and get on the
wafer wire starting off with new Arizona
Cardinals starting tight end trait
McBride gonna get run against the
Broncos the Buccaneers and the Falcons
in weeks 15 through 17 and with McBride
consensus number one tight end coming
out of the class this year and just a
bit of a rarity in terms of how ready he
has been as a receiver I mean usually we
see these tight ends have to deal with
you know blocking and receiving on a
professional level playing that in line
tight end position and it can give them
a lot of problems and because of that we
usually don't see rookie tight ends
traditional rookie tight ends perform
well in fantasy I mean since 2010 it's
Evan Ingram who needed the help of an
obj you know ankle break to actually get
that big time roll Rob Gronkowski
arguably the best tight end of all time
and Kyle Pitts who is basically playing
wide receiver this is the only rookie
tight ends to be top 12 fantasy options
since 2010 so what Trey McBride
obviously he wasn't going to be beating
out Zach ertz after he got paid this off
season but now it does look like he
could have the sort of every down role
that we need to see out of our top tier
fantasy tight ends so last week he had
an over 90 snap count after Zach ertz
exited the picture if he keeps that this
week and moving on Trey McBride's gonna
be awfully tough to keep out of the top
10 options at the position especially
when this great schedule comes around so
still a chance that Max Williams who is
their starter last season could come
back he was on the practice squad he
could get elevated this way we can split
things up a little more than we would
like but ceiling is the roof for Trey
McBride down the stretch thanks to this
lovely schedule
from the chat before we get to our final
guy here at King Carlito Deontay Johnson
or George Pickens still giving Deontay
the slight benefit to doubt guys I think
these Steelers breakouts are coming not
to brag but when I'm watching these all
22 stuff out here like not I had never
been more certain at the ante Johnson is
a great wide receiver this season
despite the lack of success I mean 81
targets without a touchdown this year
nobody else is even close to that the
man is due he almost had a touchdown
last week on a nice double move just got
overthrown and then he got held
cornerback fell down had a legit 70-yard
chance there Pickett just couldn't quite
put it on him so unfortunate but I do
think we'll see some better days to come
from both of them from at Corey
santovinia Tony or Slayton for the flex
shout out there Slayton doing some good
work lately but we gotta go with Darius
Tony only 17 pass attempts for Daniel
Jones last week and hey and obviously
Darius Slayton made the most out of
those but with Tony Miko horman's on IR
Juju Smith Schuster likely going to be
out of this game with a concussion I do
think Tony's going to have the volume to
match again just some out of this world
Talent we've seen from this dude I mean
he just moves differently I know it's a
small sample size but just watch the
freaking film on this dude we don't see
wide receivers moving like Kadarius Tony
can't with the ball in his hands final
note guys before we get on to our
defense Tyler Conklin really set up well
down the stretch he's gonna get the
Lions the Jaguars and the Seahawks in
weeks 15 through 17 and don't look now
but Tyler Conklin even already having
had to buy the overall PPR tight end six
on the season so has a tight end three
and a tight end one finish to his name
and it hasn't been the most he hasn't
been the most reliable tight end but
again you put a tight end that we have
seen have a top three ceiling this year
you take away a bunch of injured guys
that you know we've had unfortunately
deal with like Dallas Goddard and you
get this schedule Tyler Conklin don't
want to say League winning play down the
stretch but I wouldn't be surprised if
he takes one of those matchups really
booms could be useful for a tight end
needy roster and guys before we get on
to some more star are sick questions
want to talk about the best fantasy
defenses here in weeks 15 through 17. so
at the top of our charts with the
brightest blue possible showing how good
they are we have a bunch of AFC West
squads the Chargers the Raiders and the
Chiefs all getting to you know live up
with some of those matchups against the
Broncos late in the season and
accordingly they do have great end of
the season matchups versus the offenses
they're going to be facing so really
those are my big three recommendations
the Raiders they're getting the Patriots
the Steelers and the 49ers in the final
three weeks the Chiefs who get the
Texans the Seahawks and the Broncos over
the final three weeks and the Chargers
Titans Colts and Rams I mean just
looking at those quarterbacks involved I
would say the Chargers if they're out
there I know this had already been a
popular defense but getting a healthy
Joey Bosa back potentially and just
having to get to face Ryan Tannehill
Matt Ryan or Sam Ellinger and then
Matthew Stafford John Wolford down the
stretch give me the charger slightly
ahead of the Raiders and Chiefs as the
best DST to have in the fantasy football
playoffs and with that everybody let's
jump into personalized fantasy advice
presented by State Farm where the
personal price plan is all about
creating a price just for you from at
coach what's up coach Mooney Tony and
Deontay again my thoughts with Kadarius
Tony is that if we do get jesusa out who
has not practiced this week had a really
scary concussion hope he is going to be
okay already have Miko Hartman on IR
that was the first uh you know thing the
first Domino to fall and with Juju out
to cadera's Tony is a top 20 wide
receiver for me this week give me him
out of that group from at Thomas Perez
Alan Robinson over at Nico Collins
hmm
I would I would go Allen Robinson over
Nico Collins at this point I mean shout
out Bennett scroll Nick you know we have
van Jefferson out there but a-rob really
should be the number one in Los Angeles
hopefully getting the sort of force fed
volume that just hasn't been available
for him while playing across from Cooper
cops so Matthew Stafford is progressing
through the concussion protocol expected
to start this week give me Alan Robinson
from at Cape pat12. one player I should
go out there and get at the deadline
hope you guys tuned in last week we went
over a bunch of these guys to go out
there and potentially snag but I do
think moving forward again adjusting
even after another week of
disappointment for some of these guys
these Pittsburgh Steelers wide receivers
Deontay Johnson and George Pickens it
has not been there for them this year
but keep in mind guys we now only have a
one game sample size without Chase
Claypool in that picture so it really
wasn't all that realistic to expect
these guys to pull away from each other
and have consistency in this passing
game that had a brutal schedule that
didn't have an efficient quarterback
under Center and had a lot a Target
competition but you take away Claypool
and all of a sudden I do think there
should be enough meat on the bones for
Deonte who continues to see more targets
than anyone else and Pickens who don't
look now is actually starting to get
that chase Claypool small rushing roll
attached so I'm not saying we can expect
Pickens you know have that goal line
Rush attempt every week but how many
wide receivers are getting that
opportunity in the first place so
haven't seen the best days yet from
these Pittsburgh Steelers wide receivers
and because of that I think you can go
get them out of wide receiver three dare
I say even wide receiver for price and
you can see wide receiver 2 production
down the stretch when it matters most
from at Ziggy DJ Moore or Gabriel Davis
now that we know Gabriel Davis isn't
going to be playing in six feet of snow
like my God can you imagine that Devin
Singletary couldn't even look out of his
face mask but yes give me Gabriel Davis
we'll have some bus but the booms are so
worth it continue to live on with
Gabriel Davis from at ftbl Fan uh DJ
Moore or Deontay Foreman gonna be riding
with Deontay Foreman I will say guys if
you are looking for someone that may be
so high on though I do think it's
Deontay he's played some great ball this
year there's no denying that just
realize the Panthers and two of his
three big performances had double digit
leads and then the other one it was that
overtime game against the Falcons so
when they got blown out against the
Bengals I mean Deontay Foreman didn't
even have 10 touches he finished with 43
scoreless yards and that was without
chuba hubber back who was a game time
decision last Thursday night so the
first game with his Panthers team like
chuba worked ahead of Deontay and I
definitely think Foreman has earned the
right to be the lead back moving forward
but it's a panther's offense that we're
not expect acting you know too many
games where they're going to be winning
by double digit points and that could
provide some rough negative game script
for him moving forward
from Marco pimento Damien Harris or
McKinnon this week in full PPR yeah I'm
going with McKinnon like kind of lost in
the whole Isaiah Pacheco hype which is
warranted I get it is the fact that
Jared McKenna is still in this backfield
too and he's been the one catching six
plus passes here over the last few weeks
so look weeks one through seven I
believe he didn't catch more than three
in a game it's not necessarily a
guarantee that he's going to keep having
this much volume but man no me call no
Juju Clyde Edwards hilarious apparently
not in the doghouse I guess but just
really you know down and out of luck at
this point Jared McKinnon could emerge
as one of Patrick Mahomes most trusty
targets here down at the stretch
all right guys I just want to let this
chat know that I love to start sick
questions especially here so anything
you got going with start sit keep them
coming big weeks here I know there's a
lot of buys out there and hey you know I
think I ranked 160 170 players this week
so whatever you have whatever the league
format type is hit me with any start
sits that you got from at Stephen Corona
Swift or Williams this week I need to go
Jamal Williams I could because we need
to see Dan Campbell actually give Swift
the ball again I mean at this point I'm
starting to wonder is it even a
situation where the injury is impacting
it or Dan Campbell induce Staley the
running back coach getting annoyed about
Swift's you know kind of Boomer bust
running style in this situation so with
swift look we've I don't need to see any
more to know the guy's a great player
he's averaging over seven yards per
touch this season only running back to
be doing that but guys last week he
practiced some fall on Friday he wasn't
on the injury report and he comes out
there and he had five or six touches so
we need to see DeAndre Swift actually
displacing just Justin Jackson has the
clear-cut number two running back in
this backfield give me Jamal Williams
Because as we've seen the last two weeks
the lions are not afraid to give him
literally three times as many
opportunities as DeAndre Swift even if
you know you and me were coaching the
Lions obviously we would have a
different backfield style from at Q13
pick 2 Amari Cooper Gabriel Davis and
Kenyan Drake I'm expecting uh Gus
Edwards to be back here for the Ravens
so with that even though Drake isn't
useless I mean he has been playing well
maybe we see a bit of a hot hand
approach with Amari Cooper and Gabe
Davis I mean these are weekly top 20
wide receivers so I might consider Drake
if we still had to worry about that snow
game but again Brown's bill is being
played in the friendly confines of that
Dome up there in Detroit give me the
wide receivers
Pickens or Garrett Wilson have PPR it's
so close man I have them ranked right
next to each other I do think Garrett
Wilson deserves the benefit of doubt him
before the buy we have finally seen Zach
Wilson actually be able to give him a
chance to be featured so the one thing I
will say is a contingent on Corey Davis
needs to remain sidelined so he wasn't
practicing on Wednesday and Robert salad
did say that he has a chance to play but
if Corey Davis stays out yes it matters
you know we actually saw Corey Davis out
produce Garrett Wilson before getting
injured uh once Zach Wilson came under
Center assuming Corey Davis is out
giving Garrett Wilson because he's the
only guy right now in this passing game
Zach Wilson is seemingly down to trust
from at BR fans start Lamar Jackson or
Justin Fields this week what a freaking
time to be alive huh I have them pretty
much right next to each other
ah this is so tough I'm gonna go with
Justin Fields I think right now Justin
Fields just has the sort of bigger
rushing role Lamar Jackson at this point
and sadly enough I'm almost more
confident in the Chicago Bears passing
game and that's not a big time
indictment on Lamar Jackson but similar
to Green Bay like it's a passing game
that we definitely didn't think was
going to be all that fantastic this year
but guess what when you take away those
guys when Rashad Bateman gets hurt Mark
Andrews has been hurt there's just not
that many places to go with the ball so
you have to go back to week three guys
to find the last time that Lamar Jackson
finished better than the qb10 in fantasy
so he's always got that high floor
thanks to that rushing but Justin Fields
four straight weeks as the top five
fantasy quarterback let's give him the
nod over Lamar in this one and guys
keep on coming if you got them at
Clayton colattos Gabe Davis or Michael
Pittman I will be going with Michael
Pittman thanks to Matt Ryan being back
under Center would have been nice to
know uh Jeff Saturday like if he had to
had the name Sam Ellinger as the starter
in that opening press conference but now
that Matt Ryan's back under Center
Michael Pittman's back to being a top 15
wide receiver and don't forget about
Paris Campbell either guys three
straight top 12 finishes for him
specifically with Matt Ryan under Center
getting force fed into underneath areas
of the field I don't think it's a
coincidence that kept on keeping on with
Naim Heinz out of the picture from at
little Rudy official Justin fields or
Josh Allen okay now now you're being a
little crazy here Rudy great problem to
have but give me Josh Allen the guy is
about to have his third straight overall
qb1 fantasy season the only two guys to
ever do that in NFL history are Brett
Favre and Steve Young so continue to
give me Josh Allen and it's just wild
how he's having like real in real life
like a down stretch over the past few
weeks it's a relative down stretch
because it's still Josh Allen out there
but we can all agree I mean you don't
score a second half touchdown in three
straight games like okay we can say
that's not quite as great as usual and
he's still been the fantasy qb3 qb3 and
qb11 so especially guys in Fantasy
Football Josh Allen never take him out
of that qb1 spot and with that everybody
let's go wrap up another edition of BR
Fantasy Live really appreciate you guys
tuning in each and every week we're
going to have a slight time adjustment
next week with Thanksgiving going out
there not exactly trying to compete with
the Cowboys game in the middle of the
day of course so Wednesday at 3 P.M
Eastern is our current projected start
time so we'll have more notes out before
then but come back tune in we'll get
those start sick questions ahead of
three games on Thursday and obviously
plenty more to come over the weekend so
thank you guys for tuning in to BR
fantasy I'm Ian hardits and until next
time take care everybody
foreign
[Music]